so we just heard from the dep's jeffrey
donaldson who was pretty clear that he
is prepared to effectively block the
forming of the executive or the north
island assembly until there's action on
the protocol
is he holding people to ransom here
well good evening sophie great to be
with you and as you've just heard as
we've all just heard the current
operation of the northern ireland
protocol is disrupting that delicate
balance in the belfast agreement and so
it's absolutely right that the
government's going to take action um to
protect the peace and the stability that
the people of northern ireland need and
deserve um the truth is
we agreed in northern ireland protocol
in good faith and the eu have pursued a
very legalistic approach to things so um
you know they have confirmed that
they're not going to change their
mandate um in uh its current form uh the
the northern ireland protocol is here to
stay in their view and that's
undermining the belfast agreement so
that is why uh we are determined to seek
change
i'm really interested to find out what
action you are planning on taking
because obviously i'm hearing you know
from many people yourself and other
ministers as well that you agree that
something needs to be done
what exactly are you planning on doing
scrapping checks between all checks
between great britain and northern
ireland and the irish sea stopping
customs arrangements stopping filling
out forms and are you prepared to do
that unilaterally because it does feel
as if the eu well they've been very
clear so they don't want to renegotiate
well look no decisions have been taken
on exactly the way forward at this stage
but it's clear to everyone that the
situation is a very serious one and as i
say the eu have said that they are fixed
in uh their position at this moment in
time so it is right that we uh leave
open any action that's necessary to
preserve uh stability and peace in
northern ireland the foreign secretary
of course is responsible and you'll have
to speak to her about uh her latest work
uh in this regard but the truth is we've
got to solve the problems here because
some of the eu's proposals don't no
don't just not fix the problem they
actually make it worse there'd be more
paperwork for businesses and for the
people of northern ireland and the role
of the european court of justice would
still uh not be addressed and this isn't
what people of northern ireland need so
that's why uh nothing's been ruled out
at this stage i mean it feels to me like
you're
just so far away from the eu on this
that you may as well be on different
planets it's very difficult to see an
agreement uh being made in the time
frame that we're talking about so are we
talking about unilateral action which
could lead as you know to the eu
deciding to put up tariffs effectively a
trade war is that a price worth paying
well we have spent now something like 16
months trying to find solutions with the
eu with our friends and neighbours we
want to have a strong positive relation
uh relationship with the eu and you know
our command paper made clear that we're
we're absolutely prepared to carry on uh
with the checks on goods that are at
real risk of entering the eu single
market that's the intention of the
northern ireland protocol but the truth
is that two thirds of all the checks the
customs checks around the border of the
eu are now being conducted uh on the
island of ireland this isn't right it's
disproportionate it's overly legalistic
and it's got to change so we have worked
hard to make the protocol work we've
spent hundreds of millions of pounds on
the trader support service
and the movement assistance scheme only
last week um though we we have to learn
that the eu is refusing to use that
purpose-built id system that we set up
so
we've tried to make it work we've
negotiated with try to find solutions
and uh you know we will continue to want
to seek to
arrive at a positive outcome for
everyone involved but as i say it's
important that no uh nothing's ruled out
at this stage and as is at this moment
in time no absolute decisions have been
taken okay a bit of a sort of rough
direction of travel i think they're
emerging now i'm keen to talk a bit
about the cost of living because in the
queen's speech the prime minister said
that he would be saying more about help
in the coming days this has been changed
it feels today he's saying now that
there'll be more help in the months
ahead so
what exactly is the time frame that
we're talking about here
well um look i think the prime minister
is absolutely right that we will always
continue to do whatever we can to help
people um but it's important to
recognize what we've already done
we've provided
all people in homes have banned a tod
with 150 pound tax rebate on their
council tax uh we've been providing uh
everyone with a salary boost uh through
the national living wage the lowest paid
uh workers have been getting a salary
boost and indeed others will be getting
a tax cut through the ni reductions 330
pound average tax cut coming later this
year for those on universal credit we've
cut the tapering so they keep more of
what they earn around a thousand pounds
extra on average and we've increased the
size of the household support fund to
one billion pounds so a lot has already
been done but it of course um i
understand uh as much as anyone else
that the cost of living um is something
that we've got to continue to work on
and that's why we've got to grow our way
out of this uh through new trade deals
around the world creating new jobs you
say that you know you understand that
more needs to be done it does feel like
there is an acceptance among many
of uh your colleagues that this is a
huge crisis for people uh people are
really really worried and i think many
people are gonna be one wondering about
when they can expect a bit more help
boris johnson has been showing a bit of
ankle on this but when can we expect it
do you think it will be before the
summer recess
well um as uh the chance has already
outlined there will be this reduction to
national insurance uh later this year
which will give um
the average person a 330 pound uh
reductions once you put it up to be fair
it's not a tax cut is it and actually to
be honest the more people i speak to in
your party the more people seem to be
saying that you wouldn't see more tax
cuts is that something that we should be
expecting tax cuts
well first of all people on lower
incomes will be paying less national
insurance than they would have done even
before the recent changes which are
there to fund the health service but
actually um yes as a conservative of
course i believe in cutting taxes and
the chancellor has also outlined a
reduction in income tax in due course
but importantly as i say we can't just
um continue um to spend as the labour
party would do spend our way uh or
trying to spend our way out of every
crisis we've got to make sure that we're
growing our economy and that's why we've
got a long-term economic growth
agenda including new trade deals with
countries around the world not only
australia and new zealand the deals
we've already agreed but with india and
with the
gulf cooperation council with canada
with mexico these are the plans ahead
that will create great new jobs for
people across our united kingdom okay i
just want to read a quote by
one of your mp colleagues a backbencher
conservative about bencher lee anderson
who was in the house of commons bit
earlier now he said
i think you'll see firsthand that
there's not this massive use of food
banks in this country we've got
generation after generation who cannot
cook properly they can't cook a meal
from scratch and they cannot budget
do you agree with mr anderson that there
isn't a massive use for food banks in
the country it's just that we've got
generations who can't cook properly
well uh no i don't i i think probably
what he's uh what you've approached is
being taken out of contest what i would
say
is that uh food banks are uh you know a
great example of how the british people
support those who are in need uh of
course as i've said we've been providing
additional support through universal
credit by um improving the amount of
money that people can keep that they
earn um and i i'd observe um that uh you
know the opportunity to create new jobs
and give people the security of a pay
packet is actually the way forward and
uh i i know that those jobs that are
export-led that are trading with the
world um are actually paid on average
seven percent higher than other jobs in
the economy so this shows that if we get
out there and uh continue to grow our
economy get people into well-paid jobs
uh trade with countries around the world
um we've already struck deals with
something like 70 countries with a
value of something like 800 billion
pounds that's how we're going to make
sure that we're delivering not only the
benefits of brexit but making sure that
everyone uh can live better lives in the
years ahead uh very quickly uh because i
am out of time is there going to be an
emergency budget
as far as i'm aware um the uh the
chancellor and the prime minister are in
lockstep on this that we will continue
to provide support this was a queen
speech
i'm still not sure is that going to be
an emergency
and the chancellor will of course make
sure that the right support is provided
at the right time is there going to be
an emergency budget
as far as i'm aware the the chancellor
and the prime minister absolutely i want
and are going to provide the support uh
in the way that we've always done uh
making sure that um we're creating
schemes like are you hinting at a
network
i generally can't work out if you're
hinting at a no or a yes
is it no or
i can't work it out
as far as i'm aware uh the fact that we
have put one billion pounds in the
household supports fund that's already
going to local councils demonstrate some
got support but we'll keep everything
under review